there has been a reversal of this most
controversial signing david goodwilly
was signed by wraith rovers who play
here at stark's park in kirkaudi earlier
in the week it prompted an outcry
because he is a rapist he is adjudged or
was a judge by a civil court in 2007 to
have raped a woman laterally he's been
playing for clyde football club
previously played for blackburn rovers
and dundee united but he was playing for
clyde signed by wraith rovers and that
prompted an outcry with prominent
supporters including the former prime
minister gordon brown very critical so
too val mcdermott the famous crime
writer big fan steeped in wraith rovers
history her father was the scout who
spotted the great jim baxter she has
been a short sponsor that stand is named
the val mcdermott stan she became a
board member she cut ties and
effectively led a very fast growing
campaign against the signing the captain
of the women's team
left
wraith rovers women's side so there was
a huge amount of protests joined by
nicolas sturgeon as well she was
critical of scotland's first minister
sponsors
uh were withdrawing their funding board
directors
stepped down so there was huge pressure
on this club in kirkaudi and this
morning in a statement on the club
website they have announced uh that he
won't be selected for the club and they
are in discussions with him about his
contract so he's clearly on his way out
i'll read you some of the uh that club
statement it is a foolsome apology
they say uh they want to apologize this
is a chairman i first want to apologize
wholeheartedly to our fans sponsors
players and the wider wraith rovers
community for the anguish and anger
caused over the past few days we got it
wrong he's he says in reaching our
original decision we focused far too
much
on football matters and not enough on
what the decision would mean for our
club and the community as a whole over
the past few days uh we listened
carefully to the fans who got in touch
i'm very grateful for their honesty as
chairman as a board and as a management
team this statement says we have all
learned a hard but valuable lesson
statement calls it a very unfortunate
episode bitterly regretted by the club
who say they are now wholly committed to
making things right and the statement
says i can therefore confirm that
following a meeting of the wraith
rover's board
the player will not be selected by
wraith rovers and we will enter into
discussions
with the player regarding his
contractual position we share a desire
to do what's best for our club and we'll
be doing everything in our part to
regain the trust and confidence of the
rafe rovers family julianna i can tell
you just looking at my twitter timeline
it's clear that that road to recovery
may be a long one many people saying
well luke that's fine but this the
signing of a rapist should never have
happened in the first place it may be a
long road to recovery but they have
taken a step on that road within the
past half hour